Je me demande ce qui se passe dans la tête des chats. Par exemple, j'ai acheté un panier à mon chat
un beau panier de haute qualité
et il dort...
dans l'évier.
Quand tu cohabites avec un chat, il y a des trucs que tu peux pas faire. Tu peux pas faire tes lacets.
Être devant l'ordi tranquille.
Tu peux pas faire à manger est t'absenter plus de deux minutes.
Ou avoir un canapé en bon état,hein,
ça c'est impossible.
Au début tu l'empêches de faire ses griffes sur le canapé, mais au bout de 4.800 fois ou tu le répètes
tu te dis juste oh et puis tant pis j'aurai un canapé de merde.
Moi je vis avec mon chat, on est intime et un chat ça n'a pas le chromosome de la gêne. Ils sont jamais gênés.
dès fois il fait des trucs, euh...prtt
hum,hum..
Merlin tu peux arrêter de me regarder stp, ça me bloque là.
Merci
Je sais pas, les humains ils font jamais ça quoi.
Euh, David pourquoi tu me regardes là? - Parce que j'aime bien
Si tu as un chat, je pense que tu connais et que tu utilise régulièrement cet objet: Le rouleau ramasse-poils.
Tous les jours avant de sortir de chez moi ben, je me roule que le corps.
Ce truc là ça rend fou, ça devient un toc. Moi je roulotte tout, parfois même jeu roulotte les poils perdus de mon chat
directement sur mon chat
Bon après faut pas trop le faire non plus.
"Bonjour, je suis actuellement à une couille."
Les chats ils font toujours des trucs trop marrant, mais dès que tu sors ton téléphone pour les filmer
ils ont peur et ils arrêtent.
Du coup, c'est très rare d'avoir une vidéo vraiment marrante de ton chat.
J'ai presque envie de poser une caméra de surveillance pour voir ce qu'il fait quand je suis pas là.
On s'en va et on laisse le chat tout seul pour voir s'il fait des trucs de ouf pendant que je suis pas là.
Ok c'est parti. J'éteins les lumières.
Un chat et un chien c'est vraiment pas pareil.
Tu sais quand tu rentres chez toi et que t'as un chien, ton chien vraiment il te fait
la fête, il te kiff, il te saute dessus.
~Chanson Ed Sheeran~
Quand tu rentres chez toi et que t'as un chat, c'est pas la même ambiance.
Merlin, ouuh !
Je suis de retour à la maison !
Limite c'est toi qui lui fait la fête quoi.
Coucou, papa est rentré !
C'est vrai que quand on y pense, les chiens il y en a qui ont un métier quoi.
Il y a des chiens pompiers, chiens flics chiens de la montagne
qui sauvent des vies, chiens guides pour aveugles.
Alors que les chats, au maximum de leurs compétences, ils jouent avec un bouchon.
Je suis désolé mais... c'est des grosses merdes.
Même si j'adore les chats, je vois pas trop ce qu'ils pourraient faire comme métier.
Vous chercher un boulot ?
Hahahaha
Ok, je regarde un peu votre CV.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on a un niveau des compétences ?
Pisser sur la moquette, boire l'eau sale de la vaisselle et réveiller les gens à 6h du mat'.
Bon, c'est pas fifou, hein. Je vais sincère avec vous, ce que vous pouvez faire actuellement c'est que dalle.
Ce que tu vas faire, c'est que tu va prendre tes petites moustaches et ta petite queue et tu vas te casser, d'accord ?
Suivant !
Ah si ! Dès fois mon chat me ramène des cadeaux qu'il a trouvé à l'extérieur,
mais c'est des cadeaux avec sa vision à lui.
Merlin m'a fait un nouveau petit cadeau, un putain de ver de terre dégueulasse.
Putain, mais arrête le tuer wesh !
J'aimerais bien qu'un jour il me ramène un truc qui me soit vraiment utile.
C'est pour moi c'est un petit cadeau ?
C'est trop mignon !
Ah ben, génial ! J'espère que vous vous êtes bien foutus de ma gueule.
Au fait, j'ai une put*** de surprise pour vous.
Mon co**** de maître a utilisé sa YouTube money pour m'acheter pleins d'objets what the fuck pour chats.
Ca tue sa mère !
Mais la vidéo est encore en montage, alors je vous balance un petit teaser.
Allez, je vous laisse.
Je dois me lécher le c** et niq*** et le canapé. Ciao !